urgency is unbelievably important when
you're talking about not little changes
but big changes indeed the pattern that
we found through lots and lots of
research and there were we are we in the
case of Qatar International are helping
companies with right now step one is
creating a higher sense of urgency among
as many people as possible in an
organization and what that means is not
urgency in the sense of oh my goodness
oh my goodness you know running around
the circle's more meetings PowerPoint
slides it's it's this determinant first
of all it's an intellectual belief that
there's there are great opportunities
out there there are also hazards and
we've got to do something about that and
it's this gut level determination that I
feel feel like I've got to get up every
single day and do something that'll help
us even if it takes us three years to
mobilize people and take advantage of
this big opportunity or to make sure we
get out of the way of this of this
hazard as it turns out if you don't have
enough people with that frame of mind
it's like putting up a tall building and
you don't put in the what is that the
pylons deep enough they really are the
structure that that that supports
everything that keeps things moving
around that gets people into it and I
want to not I have to frame or mind the
number of companies we've seen that are
good companies that take off again very
often with this mode of you know what's
the problem six the smartest guys in the
room what's the problem what's the
solution now execute and the level of
urgency in the company to want to do
anything about that is about you know
two percent that becomes an anchor on
Action because those people don't
help out there and if you can get this
sense of real urgency lots of people
wanting to seeing it sing the big
opportunity and wanting to jump up every
day and do something even if it's a
little five minutes of something they
throw into the meeting that helps guide
that meeting in a way that's different
even if it's a role modeling for ten
minutes as they're going down the hall
you get enough people of doing that and
it is unbelievable the energy that
starts to go into the system so sense of
urgency is huge and it's what we find is
almost the first step the first phase if
you will in a large-scale change process
where you see a relationship of one unit
I'm stick with me while I call it unit
being heavily influenced by another unit
changing we see that most often is
inside a company where you have for
example these two large organizations
they are separate organizations but one
for example is is this big engineering
piece and the other is the field sales
piece and they operate independently but
as you can imagine they're very very
interdependent inter dependent because
ultimately the engineering comes up with
the products that the sales people have
to sell the sales people are out there
with their pulse on the market that you
need back into the engineering people
and there's one case we know right now
where the field sales guys are going
through a huge change they figured it
out they're basically using the H step
method that we've found for years now
and what what's going to happen there's
tension already because as they move
this engineering group is going to have
to move with them and so these guys are
beginning to say wake up and say woo
we're going to have to go through some
large-scale changes to or the company
isn't going to work and they're more
complacent because they've been very
successful their thought of within our
industry is a really really you know
number one engineering group and so but
these feel sales guys are not going to
change not going to slow down they
they're kind of taping leaps and leaps
and what is happening i think is some of
the smart people over an engineering are
kind of watching this and they are now
beginning to get this sense of urgency
going among people around them and
they're watching how these guys are
doing it and eventually the second group
is going to have huge influence if you
will the first group over the second
group so the two can kind of pull
together and
and and move along the other way that
you see change in one organization
affecting another is that they're in for
example the same industry and there's
enough crosstalk across the industry
industry associations people change jobs
across companies that one company really
starts going out front and they do it
not just by doing a bit a little bit
better job of selling or or incrementing
the products but they really do it by
changing the way they operate big change
and they've got enough communication in
connections between the two companies
that the other company will see this
pretty quickly and somebody says hey you
know they're onto something and if we
don't get on to it pretty quickly we're
going to be in trouble and so we get
this it's not quite a copying effect but
the second company is smart enough to
watch carefully what the first company
is doing and they moved so it's the
leader company has a huge impact without
ever running or being the top guys in
the second company you see that too